>>> TONIGHT, A CNN INVESTIGATION
OF HUNTEBIDEN'S EMAILS
REVEALING YEARS OF HIGH INCOME
AND HIGHER DEBT.
MORE THAN $500,000 IN UNPAID
BILLS.
REPEATED WARNINGS FROM BANKS.
THE IRS EVEN THREATENED NOT TO
RENEW HUNTER BIDEN'S PASSPORT.
THIS AS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WEIGHS POSSIBLE CHARGES AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT'S SON.
JOE GRIFFIN IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: THE EMAILS POSTED
BY A RIGHT WING OPERATIVE ON THE
INTERNET HAVE LONG BEEN USED AS
A POLITICAL WEAPON AGAINST JOE
BIDEN.
BUT IT'S HIS SON THAT IS FACING
POTENTIAL CHARGES.
PROSECUTORS IN DELAWARE ARE
NARROWING IN ON POTENTIAL TAX
VIOLATIONS IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION OF HUNTER BIDEN.
THESE E-MAILS, AUTHENTICATED FOR
CNN, REVEAL HUNTER BIDEN WAS
WARNED ABOUT DEEP DEBTS AND
YEARS OF BACK TAXES.
THIS, DESPITE HAVING A LAVISH
INCOME THAT INCLUDED AS MUCH AS
$50,000 A MONTH FOR SITTING ON
THE BOARD OF BARISMA, THE
UKRAINIAN ENERGY COMPANY.
A 2019 SPREAD SHEET SENT TO
BIDEN FROM HIS ASSISTANT,
DETAILS MORE THAN $500,000 IN
BILLS DUE OR PAST DUE, INCLUDING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IN TAXES
OVER SEVERAL YEARS.
THE EMAILS SHOW HE KNEW HE WAS
DELINQUENT.
OCTOBER 2018, HIS ACCOUNTANT
WROTE, THEY ARE LATE.
NOTING THAT BIDEN HAD MISSED AN
ALREADY EXTENDED TAX FILING
DEADLINE OF OCTOBER 15th.
TWO WEEKS LATER, YOUR 2017 TAX
RETURNS ARE STILL UNFILED, THE
ACCOUNTANT REMINDED BIDEN.
THE NEXT DAY, YOU NEED TO GET
2017 FILED SO WE CAN TRY TO WORK
OUT A PAYMENT SCHEDULE.
THE ACCOUNTANT TOLD BIDEN THE
IRS WAS ALSO DEMANDING A PAYMENT
FROM 2015.
THEY WANT $158,000, THE
ACCOUNTANT WROTE.
THE 2018 FEDERAL TAXES OF
$471,000 WILL BE IN ADDITION.
IRS HAS NOTIFIED THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, AND THEY WILL NOT
RENEW YOUR PASSPORT UNTIL THIS
IS RESOLVED.
>> HE WAS STRUGGLING UNDER
MASSIVE DRUG ADDICTION, AND
THAT'S HEARTBREAKING AND
PAINFUL.
>> Reporter: IN PAST INTERVIEWS,
BIDEN AND HIS EX-WIFE SAY
BIDEN'S FINANCIAL ISSUES BECAME
WORSE WITH THE DEATH OF HIS
BROTHER AND HIS DRUG USE.
>> I WENT 13 DAYS ONE TIME
WITHOUT SLEEPING.
AND SMOKING CRACK AND DRINKING
VODKA EXCLUSIVELY THROUGHOUT
THAT ENTIRE TIME.
>> Reporter: THE COUPLE DIVORCED
AND HUNTER WOULD OWE $37,000 A
MONTH IN SPOUSAL SUPPORT.
THE SPREAD SHEET SHOWS HE FELL
BEHIND.
JUST PART OF A LIFESTYLE THAT
WAS FINANCIALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
MORE THAN $65,000 OWED ON ONE
CREDIT CARD.
HE OWED AD 1700 PAYMENT ON A
PORCH.
HIS HEALTH CARE WAS BACK DUE.
AND THE ASSISTANT TRYING TO KEEP
TRACK OF IT ALL, SAYS SHE TOO
WASN'T BEING PAID.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO
DO ABOUT BILLS, HIS ASSISTANT
ASKS.
PAY THE HEALTH CARE, PAY THE
PORSCHE BIDEN RESPONDED, AND
TOLD HIS ASSISTANT TO PAY
HERSELF HALF OF WHAT SHE WAS
OWED.
HIS CREDIT CARD WAS REPEATEDLY
DECLINED.
IN A STATEMENT TO CNN, BIDEN'S
ATTORNEY ACKNOWLEDGED THE TAX
ISSUE SAYING HE'S CURRENT ON HIS
OBLIGATIONS AND COMMITTED TO
REMAINING SO AS HE CONTINUES HIS
RECOVERY FROM ADDICTION.
>> I'M COOPERATING COMPLETELY
AND I'M CERTAIN, 100% CERTAIN,
THAT, AT THE END OF THE
INVESTIGATION, THAT I WILL BE
CLEARED OF ANY WRONGDOING.
>> Reporter: EVEN IF HUNTER
BIDEN IS NEVER CHARGED WITH A
CRIME, THAT WON'T MATTER TO
REPUBLICANS, ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO MAY SHARE POWERFUL COMMITTEE
IT IS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WINS
THE PARTY IN CONGRESS, THAT
PROMISE A HUNTER BIDEN
INVESTIGATION.
>> HUNTER BIDEN IS A SHADY
BUSINESS CHARACTER.
WE FEAR THAT HE'S COMPROMISED
THIS WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE TO LET UP ON THESE
INVESTIGATIONS AND WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Reporter: JOE BIDEN IS NOT
BEING INVESTIGATED AS PART OF A
FEDERAL PROBE INTO HUNTER BIDEN.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES.
>> DREW, SOME OF THAT STUFF JUST
IS AMAZING TO SEE, PAYING HIS
ASSISTANT HALF OF WHAT SHE WAS
OWED, BUT PAY THE PORSCHE.
I'M SURE REPUBLICANS WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE HUNTER BIDEN INDICTED
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN
NOVEMBER.
BUT THE BIG QUESTION, HOW LIKELY
IS THAT?
>> Reporter: WE KNOW THIS CASE
HAS REACHED A CRITICAL JUNCTURE
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, BUT
WE KNOW THROUGH SOURCES THAT
TIMING LIKE THAT IS AN ISSUE.
THERE ARE GUIDELINES TO TRY TO
AVOID BRINGING POLITICALLY
SENSITIV